بالنسبة للسائقين ، يمكن الفوز بسباقات أو فقدانها
في الذهن باستخدام علم الأعصاب ، وجد الفريق في
Ford طريقة لمساعدة السائقين
على فهم عقولهم بشكل أفضل
واختيار الفوز بـ
[موسيقى]
بدأ الأمر بسؤال بالضبط كيف
يكون السائق في المنطقة عند المنافسة
صمم فريق من المهندسين والعلماء في شركة فورد نظام خوذة يقرأ
نشاط دماغ السائقين باستخدام مخطط كهربية الدماغ عندما
يتنافسون ،
ويظهر بحث موجات ألفا بين 8 إلى 12 هرتزًا أن موجات ألفا بين 8 إلى
12 هرتز تتعلق بأعلى أداء ، حيث تقوم
بيانات الخوذة بتدريب
نموذج ذكاء اصطناعي للتعرف على وقت
السائقين.  في حالة تركيز عميق من
خلال عوامل مثل
الانخراط المستمر في الانتباه والخطأ الذي يجمع بين
الخوذة وبيانات نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) يسمح للسائقين
بفهم مكان رفع
أدائهم لأقسام من
مسرح أو حلبة السباق التي تحتاج إلى
تركيز أكبر تساعد خوذة فورد الجديدة
السائقين على التحكم في أذهانهم  تحسين
أدائهم وربما
يقربهم من تحقيق الفوز